You need to show a
collection of places.
And at first, it seems
pretty stock standard.
Just throw together a
bunch of place names,
and you're done, right?
It's not that simple.
I'm Ankur Kotwal, and I'm
going to show you two ways
to display such collections.
First is on the map itself.
Here, we remove the UI
and let the map markers
be the primary point
of interaction.
This makes for a very
immersive experience.
However, it's only effective
if the markers fit comfortably
on one screen.
If the user has
to zoom or scroll,
the emphasis of your
collection is lost.
For example, train
stations near me
works well since the
result are co-located.
So what should you do about the
location if they're spread out?
Well, you could show a
list with map thumbnails.
Is that even possible, is
what I hear you saying.
How can you show multiple
maps at the same time?
It is possible.
The maps API for Android
offers an ideal mode
for such scenarios.
It's called Lite mode.
Lite mode provides a static
map, effectively just
the image of a map
without the ability
to pan or tilt the camera.
This limited functionality,
however, comes with a huge win.
It's super fast,
uses less memory,
and you still get
click listeners,
markers, and polylines.
Lite mode makes it possible
to show lists of maps.
They're just images, so you
can instantiate many of these.
Best of all, enabling
Lite mode is simple.
On creation, simply specify Lite
mode in the Google Maps options
object or add the XML
property in your layouts.
At some point, you may need
to replace the Lite mode map
with the fully interactive one.
In that situation, you
can gracefully transition
into a regular map based
on the touch event.
Here we're using Android
Lollipop transitions
to navigate across screens.
For older versions of
Android, a reasonable fallback
is to create a map fragment and
animate it into place like so.
By doing this, we're able
to mix and match Lite mode
and regular maps seamlessly.
I hope you've now seen
the light, Lite mode that
is, which enables you to show
multiple maps simultaneously
while staying performant.
Check out more info
about Lite mode here.
I'm Ankur Kotwal,
and I look forward
to seeing your amazing maps.
[MUSIC PLAYING]